we now know how long the object is going
to be in the air so we're ready to
figure out how far it's going to travel
so we can just go back to kind of the
core formula and all of really
kinematics all of kind of projectile
motion or mechanical physical problems
and that's distance is equal to rate
times time distance is equal to rate
times time now we're talking about the
horizontal distance so our distance is
going to be equal to what's our rate in
the horizontal direction
what's our rate in the horizontal
direction we care about horizontal
distance traveled so our rate needs to
be the horizontal the horizontal
component of the velocity or the
magnitude of the horizontal component of
the velocity and we figured that out in
the first video that is s cosine of
theta so let's write that down right
here so our rate our rate is s cosine of
theta and how long will we be traveling
at this horizontal speed how long will
we be traveling well we'll be going at
that speed as long as we are in the air
so how long are we in the air well we
figured that out in the last video we're
going to be in the air this long 2's
sine of theta divided by G so the time
the time is going to be 2's sine theta
sine theta over G so the total distance
we're going to travel pretty straight
forward rate times time is just the
product of these two things and we could
put all of the constants out front so
it's a little bit clearer that it's a
function of theta so we can write we can
write that the distance traveled the let
me do that same green the distance
traveled as a function of theta is equal
to is equal to I'll do it in this blue
this s times 2 s divided by G is alled
in a neutral color actually this s times
2 s divided by G is 2 times s squared
over G so 2's squared over G times
cosine of theta
cosine of theta times sine of theta
times sine of theta so now we have a
general function you give me an angle
that I'm going to shoot something off at
and you give me the magnitude of its
velocity and you give me the
acceleration of gravity I guess if you
know we were on some other planet who
knows and I will tell you exactly what
the horizontal distance is